ils sont partis sans laisser de trace
vers le moyen orient des québécois des
ontariens des albertains qui les a
recrutés qui les a aidés stéphane
berthemet explique dans son livre la
fabrique du djihad comment les réseaux
sociaux peuvent faciliter la
radicalisation des jeunes
j'ai fait une expérience empirique et je
suis parti vraiment en disant je vais
voir ce que ça va donner
j'ai créé deux comptes j'ai créé un
compte sur facebook et un compte sur
twitter des comptes avec un prénom d'un
jeune d'un jeune homme que j'ai inventé
de toute pièce je voulais voir ce qui
allait lui arriver quand il allait
justement abordé les questions de
terrorisme ou de radicalisation sur sur
les réseaux sociaux et rapidement on lui
a répondu immédiatement après que le
comté commencé à débattre sur les
questions qui touchent et au djihadisme
en privé on m'a conseillé des lectures
des lectures qui sont des lectures
salafistes qui sont des lectures qui
pousse au combat et à la radicalisation
c'est qu'il n'est pas étonnant selon
cette psychologue
les groupes radicaux ont découvert les
avantages d'internet et des réseaux
sociaux et s'en servent pour recruter
les jeunes on va à travers internet et
sur tous les réseaux sociaux cherché à
établir un lien direct avec les
individus en surveillant par exemple ce
que les jeunes peuvent mettre comme une
opinion sur twitter ou sur facebook
comme opinion publique
ils deviennent faciles à retracer
stéphane bertheau mais entend le
dialogue sur sa conversion à l'islam
mais ses interlocuteurs le pressent de
s'engager
le personnage se dit alors musulmans et
là effectivement il se passe des choses
qui sont assez surprenantes c'est que
vous avez toute une communauté de gens
qui vient vous dire bravo c'est bien tu
t'es converti tu fais partie de notre
famille et vous avez ce sentiment
d'appartenance qui vous finalement vous
motive à continuer sur cette voie
ces nouveaux amis le mettre en garde et
lui disent qu'à partir de maintenant il
doit agir en secret s'il compte
déménager en terre musulmane pour
pratiquer un islam 5 ou obligera
n'affiche rien du tout si tu veux faire
la hijra sans te faire arrêter à la
frontière et confisqué son passeport
n'affiche pas tes opinions et le mieux
c'est que tu supprimes ce conte groupe
seven days charland qui est analyste en
sécurité nationale affirme que la
radicalisation sur internet est en
pleine expansion et des gens qui vont
faire plus ou moins tension alors
anonymement sur internet incluant les
légendes l'état islamique on pourrait
être surpris de voir que certaines se
cache pas du tout et mais le voleur est
tellement grand parc ont cassé deux
locales et la complexité pour les
autorités de les détecter
à sa grande surprise stéphane bertheau
mais a réussi à échanger avec un des
plus influents recruteurs français pour
l'état islamique en moins de trois
semaines
je suis en contact avec ce fameux homard
en scène qui est considéré qu'ils
étaient considérés puisqu'il vient
d'être tué il ya quelques semaines qui
était considéré comme l'un des
principaux recruteurs français dans le
pool pour le djihad en syrie c'est un
individu très médiatique parce qu'il a
fait beaucoup de vidéo qui ont contribué
à recruter beaucoup de jeunes gens en
france et en europe
le recruteur a envoyé ce message privé
au personnage de stéphane prend tout ce
que tu as comme argent vent tout ce que
tu veux
eva en italie par train jusqu'à 1000 de
la pole pour istanbul
ensuite ce nous appelle on expliquera et
on enverra quelqu'un de chercher
inch'allah c'est à ce moment là que
stéphane bertheau mais a mis fin à son
expérience
cette pression est très important moi je
les trouvais à la fois fascinante et à
la fois très inquiétante parce que
finalement vous recevez un flot
d'informations qui vont toutes dans le
même sens ça ressemble effectivement un
lavage de cerveau
ça ressemble à de la manipulation comme
on en fait dans les sectes plus la
personne semble vu
érable ouverte et influençable
évidemment plus le processus de
recrutement peut se passer rapidement je
crois qu'il ya un réel danger sur les
réseaux sociaux pour les jeunes pour les
adolescents pour des individus qui se
cherche qui cherchent une identité qui
cherchent une communauté parce que ces
gens là vont tomber très souvent
justement vers les plus radicaux
lorsqu'un jeu est rendu au point où il
s'isole dans sa chambre pour dialoguer
avec un recruteur
on est déjà rendu un peu trop loin un
peu trop tard selon plusieurs
spécialistes les seules façons de se
prémunir contre la radicalisation sur
internet c'est par la prévention la
discussion le débat et la vigilance